in their day the two reactors at trous
venus made enough power for a city the
size of manchester
this plant shut down 30 years ago but
some of its core components will be
radioactive for centuries
the remaining waste is being boxed up
for long-term storage what you can see
here is concrete boxes
inside which there's another box and
inside that
there's what's called intermediate level
waste so this is what you see
as waste that's come from
half a century of nuclear generation for
a long time the assumption was the site
to be effectively forgotten but the
energy crisis means they're being eyed
as the best places for a nuclear
renaissance
our job as magnox is to decommission the
site and do that in a safe and
sustainable way to enable this site to
be reused and regenerated for whatever
use we all decide is needed here
at a peak in 1997 15 power plants
produced more than a quarter of the uk's
electricity but by 2024 only three will
still be generating and by 2030 there'll
be just two size well b and the long
delayed hinckley c in somerset
last week at a number 10 round table the
prime minister said he wanted 25 of our
energy to come from nuclear once again
executives from rolls-royce were there
trying to persuade him of a new approach
small modular reactors we've designed
this solution in order to ensure we've
got a much more robust route to market
with a technology that can be financed
with private capital and that is by
design uh a product that is lower cost
and can be built in a factory best case
scenario worst case scenario when do you
think we'll see well hopefully if you
come and speak to me in a year's time
we'll be in the middle of those
negotiations
rolls-royce's reactor is based on its
designs used in nuclear submarines to
make smrs faster and less complex to
build they'll be prefabricated in
modules
so this is a an example of a module
right so this is one component yes
one module this is modular constructed
so it's
built in a factory environment taken to
site and then modules assembled together
so you're taking all that risk out of
the construction
while investment risks may be lower smrs
still need to be proven in the real
world
they'll face stiff competition from
rival bids for bigger nuclear plants and
neither are a quick fix for the energy
crisis
it's right perhaps that the government
has nuclear as part of
of its strategy and certainly expect
that it would do that but it's quite
wrong to think that we can we can get
nuclear in time new nuclear in time the
next winter winter after that or in fact
for many years
to some sites like this are the legacy
of an expensive and messy chapter in our
energy history to others they're
monuments to an era of high-tech
homegrown energy independence reminding
us how short-term thinking could end up
costing more in the long run
tom clark sky news north wales